je suis comédienne j'avais deux rêves
dans la vie quand j'étais petit le
premier c'était devenu de devenir
comédienne et le second de combattre les
inégalités parce que je trouvais injuste
que pour moi devenir comédienne soit une
possibilité à un rêve envisageable alors
que pour certaines personnes moins
favorisés que moi ça ne soit même pas la
peine d'y penser
parce que comme dit oscar wilde il y a
dans une nation une partie de la
population qui pense plus à l'argent que
les riches et ce sont les pauvres les
pauvres ne peuvent penser à autre chose
c'est en cela que consiste la
malédiction de la pauvreté
le premier rêve je les réaliser mais le
second pas encore alors je me suis dit
que j'allais trouver une technique pour
éradiquer les inégalités épouser un
milliardaire
j'ai calculé que si les sept milliards
d'êtres humains épousé chacun 1 dès 1826
milliardaire sous le régime de la
communauté
en seulement une génération nous
pourrions éradiquer les inégalités bon
je suis pas très bonne en probabilités
je suis meilleur en statistiques
j'ai calculé qu'aujourd'hui j'avais une
chance sur six d'épouser quelqu'un qui
souffre de la faim est pas un anorexique
1-1 malnutries une chance sur 4
d'épouser quelqu'un qui vit avec moins
d'un dollar 25 par jour
un très très pauvres d'asie ou d'afrique
une chance sur deux d'épouser quelqu'un
qui vit avec moins de deux dollars par
jour
autant dire que même en europe tu fais
rien et une chance sur
8 millions
d'épouser un milliardaire est ce que
quelqu'un dans la salle gagnent plus de
10 millions d'euros par an encore une
salle de pauvres
c'est pas grave on est pauvre on est
pauvre mais on est heureux
ouais alors un milliardaire j'explique
parce que pour les pauvres les sommes
peuvent paraître un peu flou un
milliardaire c'est quelqu'un qui à 999
millions +1 y en a seulement 1826 dans
le monde sait rien ce serait des animaux
ce serait une espèce protégée
c'est pour ça qu'on n'a pas le droit de
les tuer pour leur fourrure
et d'en faire des sushis en tête l'homme
le plus riche du monde c'est bill gates
en deuxième position il ya carlos slim
helu il à 15% du mexique
il a le téléphone les hôtels la
télévision du coup faut pas faire un
monopoly avec lui chez moi chez moi chez
moi je loge est juste derrière
warren buffett c'est le pdg de berkshire
hathaway un fonds d'investissement il
achète des actions pour les vendre
lui il a rien à fabriquer rien inventé
et il a 50 milliards j'adore
ils changent jamais de voiture il a
toujours la même maison il a épousé la
serveuse du café d'en face
il a voyagé une seule fois dans sa vie
il/elle en chine a trouvé ça nul et son
truc c'est de manger un tibotec le
vendredi et les numéros 2 3 sur 7
milliards et quand il sera mort il va
donner toute sa fortune à bill gates
pour son association caritative ir peine
des écoles
non mais vachement bien au pinceau il va
tour donner aux pauvres ça je comprends
pas toute sa vie il a vécu du travail
des pauvres il a essayé de ne pas les
payer beaucoup
il a plutôt réussi et à la fin il leur
dit quoi
surprise c'était une blague fallait pas
exploiter les gens si tu voulais pas
gagner d'argent en fait c'est comme les
gens qui pêche pour le plaisir après ram
est le poisson dans l'eau fair play le
beau geste
moi je trouve pas que ce soit un beau
geste d'humilier un poisson et du trou
et la bouche warren il appauvrit les
gens juste pour le sport alors vous
allez me dire éradiquer les inégalités
c'est bien mais comment faire pour
épouser un milliardaire c'est très
simple il faut étudier la liste de
forbes
c'est une liste qui paraît tous les ans
avec le nom des milliardaires par ordre
décroissant avec leur photo moi j'en ai
fait des posters george clooney il est
plus beau mais il n'est pas dans la
liste
y'a hugh grant non pas celui là l'autre
celui-là c'est un pauvre son homonyme
c'est le pdg de monsanto pour devenir
milliardaire il suffit juste d'avoir une
bonne idée
lui il a eu l'idée de breveter les
graines les semences les pommes fallait
juste y penser
dans la liste de forbes la pâte
d'acteurs pas de footballeurs pas de
chanteur il ya un clown guy un québécois
le créateur du cirque du soleil lui il
est mille 6e lepeu super mal pour un
cracheur de feu et puis lui c'est un
vrai milliardaire ses dernières vacances
pour son anniversaire il les a passées à
ce sur ude c'est pas en russie à ses
plus hauts en orbite
vous savez pas mais c'est trop ringard
de passer encore ses vacances sur la
terre je ne peux pas vraiment vous
apprendre à reconnaître un milliardaire
dans une soirée
il ya ya pas vraiment de signe par
contre je peux vous apprendre à
reconnaître un pauvre s'il porte sur lui
des marques que vous reconnaissez le
petit cheval de ralph lauren une rolex
une porsche c'est un pauvre un
milliardaire n'a pas de signes
extérieurs de richesse
en tout cas pas sur lui abramovitch le
milliardaire russe sont signes
extérieurs de richesse c'est chelsea le
club de football anglais
bon je vous ai fait des fiches je vous
ai mis un beau pour pas vous décourager
larry ellison c'est le pdg d'oracle java
sur les ordinateurs un truc gratuit on
sait pas comment il fait
quoi il est bien attendez de voir les
autres vous allez le regretter
george soros il a inventé les hedge
funds
bon après il a ruiné l'angleterre le
franc est en ce moment ils adorent
l'euro attention plus belle progression
de l'année grâce à qui grâce à nous zara
amancio ortega quatrième fortune
mondiale
quelqu'un parle espagnol il vient juste
de perdre sa femme
attention pour les hommes talent
ça c'est jacqueline mars de 2 mars de 1
mars et ça repart
tia elle elle est super sympa vous voyez
c'est non heureusement que je suis là
pour vous indiquer les bons partis sans
moi vous étiez tous bons pour des
mariages d'amour
lakshmi mittal
il fabrique de l'acier sa plus belle
affaire c'est le kazakhstan il a acheté
un bout de pays
toute une région les mines de fer de
charbon les usines la centrale
électrique le chemin de fer du coup on
lui a fait cadeau des gens mais c'est
normal c'est un geste commercial
tous les ans il fait 10 fois le tour de
la terre avec son jet imagine les miles
d'avoir droit vice gratuit là sur pluton
pour discuter avec des milliardaires
il faut être capable de parler avec eux
de connaître un peu ce qu'ils font dans
la vie dans la liste de forbes il ya les
milliardaires dont on comprend le métier
ingvar kamprad le pdg d'ikea
on comprend il fabrique des meubles bas
après les découpe très file éminent des
toutes petites boîtes
parce que quand il était enfant elle
était très pauvre il était marchands
d'allumettes
l'asa lui restait puis après lé pdg
franchement on comprend rien il fait
quoi votre mari des algorithmes quoi il
a inventé google c'est un algorithme on
entre un mot dans le moteur de recherche
et grâce à paige rancune lignes de codes
de 2 milliards de termes avec 500
millions de variables l'information va
dans les files de l'ordinateur dans un
centre de traitement de données dans la
région il ya des rampes de serveurs
c'est climatisé faut pas qu'ils passent
trop chaud et grâce à un signal
électrique l'information revient dans
votre ordinateur via les airs et les
fibres optiques
mais est ce qui est rigolo c'est que ça
prend moins d'une seconde
aller retour c'est instantané mon mari
les 20e sur 7 milliards il est super
gentil mais franchement quand il parle
eh ben je comprends rien attention aux
arnaques dans la liste de forbes
il y à peu d'africains milliardaire très
peu d'africains milliardaire ils ont pas
choper le truc
pourtant ils essaient en ethiopie par
exemple les ethiopia c'est eux qui ont
inventé le café c'est une belle
invention de café c'est la matière
première agricole la plus échangée au
monde
le problème c'est qu'ils n'ont pas
déposé du coup ils en voient pas la
couleur
alors que nestlé cd suisse ils ont
déposé pour épouser un milliardaire
il faut aimer l'opéra je sais pas
pourquoi mais surtout lire le supplément
féminin du financial times et s'appelle
out to spend it
qu'est ce que je vais bien pouvoir en
faire ça existe vraiment mais surtout il
faut apprendre à parler jet est à dire
mon chéri tu as pas vu les clés du
falcon il faut que j'aille faire une
course à temps que j'y suis tu voudrais
pas que change d'avion
j'aime pas en navarone l'année dernière
j'ai l'impression de voler dans une
vieille robe jeanne par le dernier
modèle de chez bombardier il est trop
mignon on dirait un porte-clés 60 mètres
carrés tout en cuir et tu savais que
c'est le seul jet capable de faire le
tour de la terre avec une seule escale
c'est génial pour aller chercher les
enfants à l'école
quand je pense que 95 % de la population
mondiale n'a jamais pris l'avion
oh c'est pas grave ça veut dire que
c'est le 5 % qui restent qui s'éclate
qui pollue mais du coup chez les pauvres
ils ont fait un truc trop mignon en inde
à côté de délit ils ont installé un
boeing désaffectée et % 25 roupies
l'équivalent de 3 euros le week end ils
vont prendre l'avion en famille ils
mettent leurs jolies sari du dimanche on
déchire leur billet il ya un steward des
hôtesses de l'air un commandant de bord
on leur sert à rafraîchissement des
plateaux repas
on leur fait les consignes de sécurité
mesdames mesdemoiselles messieurs
bienvenue à bord de air nulle part
prière de bien vouloir attachez vos
ceintures faut soulever le languette
métallique comme ça en même temps vous
savez c'est vous qui les avez fabriqué
en cas de dépressurisation de l'appareil
bon peu probable
on a des masques je vais pas vous faire
le coup des gilets de sauvetage ont fait
ça pour les riches ils n'aiment pas
avoir aucun espoir mais franchement on
leur aurait mis une paire de skis à
masque un tuba
c'était la même chose tout pareil sauf
qu'ils volent pas et ben au bout de deux
heures quand ils descendent de l'avion
ils sont contents que même c'est comme à
gaza dans leurs horizons pas de zèbres
alors qu'ils peignent des ânes et les
entoure de scotch pour pas dépasser non
mais les peines vachement bien au
pinceau les milliardaires ils ont
inventé un truc incroyable c'est
l'aspirateur à sous c'est une sorte de
chemin que nous on ne connaît pas vers
où un peu dessous de chaque personne du
monde entier 120 en sifflotant
et eux ils sont derrière et ils aspirent
l'aspirateur qui ne perd pas
d'aspirations c'est dyson et les
milliardaires
voilà maintenant vous savez comment
épouser un milliardaire
comment on leur parlait apprendre à les
comprendre à les aimer j'espère que
c'est vous qui serai l'an prochain dans
la liste de forbes en 2009
au début de la crise ils étaient 7 193
aujourd'hui ils sont 1826 j'espère que
demain nous serons 7 milliards dans la
liste